[Music]
[Applause]
so
we got darren ravel on for a reason okay
nobody knows more about
these type of sports business questions
then darren revell
from the action network darren revell
has like a like
five million twitter followers i don't
know how he you know why
because darren's content is so
twitter friendly it's like the perfect
shareable
stuff like it's food or
it's prices of things gambling
darren's got it figured out man uh check
him out again
at darren revell r-o-v-e-l-l i think
most of you know that
on twitter darren what's up man it's
ross long time no talk how are you
what's up ross how are you i'm doing
fantastic okay
so we got to get into this new jersey
rule with the nfl because i'm fascinated
by this
i like talking numbers you usually know
the numbers right i just explained last
segment
why brady's upset about it i guess i
should mention
that the reason why they're doing the
rule is because the chiefs
say with all the guys in ir and practice
squad
and retired numbers that they were
running out of
jersey numbers for like running backs
right because
they are limited to whatever it was 20
to 50 or whatever it is right
they were limited this will help them
first of all i guess darren
do you buy that do you believe that
that's the number one and
only reason why they are allowing this
or do they
think this will be good for business fun
to have
players in single digit numbers etc yeah
i don't really
see the business side of it too much
other than
uh which i'm sure you were going to talk
about the idea that
you know the players can't just switch
their numbers willy-nilly with
the fact that uh you have all these guys
all these fans that are buying jerseys
um i mean that's the only thing that i
think is really intriguing other than
what you mentioned about brady which
i had no clue why he went nuts um but
your reasoning makes sense um but just
from the
from the marketing standpoint of it i
think there there is a slight
marketing advantage if you have a great
number but you can't just
change it out of nowhere and that's
where the rules of buying your jersey
come in
right so here's the deal for people that
don't know the rule is
you can change your number but if you
change your number this year
you have to buy all of the existing
inventory you can wait a year you can
say listen
i'm changing my number in 2022
which i'm curiou i'll be very curious
see how many guys change it and just pay
the inventory and how many guys just
you know kind of put their foot in the
ground i am changing it two years from
now
the question is darren because i saw i
read a story this morning
dalvin cook wants to switch to four the
vikings running back and he's currently
investigating how much inventory there
is
and how much money he'll have to pay so
i guess that's question one there and
for a guy like dalvin cook
probably the most popular jersey for the
vikings maybe theon
i don't know what kind of numbers are we
talking here do you think dalvin will
have to pay back
okay so this is where it gets really
interesting when you talk about
when this rule was originally put in
place ross
which was around 2005 or six
that's when i started reporting on this
i actually went back to my reporting
and one player can't remember who it was
investigated it and they would have to
pay 215 000
the big one was i think the 2007
season when chad johnson switched his
name to ocho cinco
wanted to just change the name on the
back still have the 85 but change his
name on the back
and he would have had to pay all the
jerseys back he did the investigating
and it was 4.8 million dollars oh my god
so now that has a lot to do with the
fact
that back then they were pre-making
a lot of the jerseys so the jerseys were
in
inventory for the entire season
obviously as you've gotten to a point
where fanatics
is selling the amount of jerseys they
are they're the only ones who have
permission to make
uh jerseys uh nfl jerseys on the spot on
order
and they do that the numbers are going
to be significantly
less because of that so like i think
dalvin cook now yes
locally team shop you'll have some
but i think most players numbers are
going to be below
150 000 because of the
on order environment we're in right now
that is really interesting okay so then
the next step of that there's two more
questions just all off of that there
one is what are they payroll deducting
the money from the guys like i
i would just say yeah i'm good for it
this is an iou like you know
are they going to payroll deduct this
amount from them i think they do
i think they do deduct for the jersey so
a lot of people don't know this you
probably do
when the pla when the players are
exchanging jerseys at the end of the
game the players are actually paying
for their own jersey i believe the
current cost is 350
you do have to pay the team um so
i and i think it's deducted um but but
does uh
do most guys know when there's minus 350
i would say
not but uh but so so that there is
already some sort of process
but yeah i assume that you're going to
probably in this case
it's not going to be a fine to the
league but it's really gonna
from the league the league's not going
to get it i would assume fanatics gets
it
now it's a fanatics you know 10 years
ago in jacksonville
and they had a room full of stuff that
didn't work out
when you see 5 000 jeremy lin mix
figurines man
that's crazy they had like this whole
room of like undesirables
that they couldn't sell any of anymore
but as i said
they've now moved into this business of
on order
you order it they make it on the spot
and they ship it and the more they can
do that
the less a player is going to have to
pay all right so and we're talking with
darren revell
wrapping up with the uh stud over at
action network at darren revell
on twitter what do the guys make off the
jersey sale in other words let's say
dalvin cook has to pay 200 grand
a lot of people are gonna buy the new
dalvin cook number four
jersey what i know the players get some
type of percentage right like what
what do they get and don't you think
he'd be able to make up for it with
people buying the ford jersey
so most of the guys are gonna make like
a standard
cut but as you get to be a bigger player
you'll make
a couple hundred thousand dollars the
top guys make
you know 1.5 1.7 million a year off
their jerseys
uh dalvin cook is probably
i would say if he had to pay a hundred
fifty thousand dollars
i'd say he depending on what type of
year he had
he'd make that back in year one yeah so
but it's a percentage of jersey sales
yes
yes the percentage of the sale got it
awesome you know why i ask you that
darren
other than me going to the buffalo bills
and having them make jerseys for like my
wife
and mom and mother-in-law i only ever
saw
two tucker 65 jerseys
like two people that actually paid for
them in buffalo
and i got a check from east bay
like did did east bay is he space still
around east
yeah yeah east bay at some point was so
they probably customized it
and if they customized it as a league as
a partner
they had to disclose that they
customized it tucker
i got a i got a check from east bay
randomly
in the offseason one time 35 no no it
was like a dollar 37 cents
okay it was like and i was like what
is this for why is espace sending me a
check but evidently those two people
that bought my jersey or one or whatever
amazing it got me a dollar darren thank
you so much man really appreciate it
you got it take care all right check him
out on twitter at darren revell
r-o-o-v-e-l-l
good info that's what i wanted